[Music]
i secretly think of pushing
everybody off into this pool including
the kids
all right so i guess my secret is that
my dad isn't
really my dad i mean he is actually that
the secret actually is that he is my dad
uh uh he
goes by another name uh and on all
registered documents he's not registered
as my dad
but he actually is my dad so it's the
opposite it's that i actually know my
dad
[Music]
okay so i was about 19 i had this
girlfriend of three years
in the beginning of our relationship um
we ended up hooking up
and then two weeks later i started to
get this weird sensation when i would
pee
and it ended up being chlamydia
so i went through this whole process of
trying to rid myself of this
nasty infection but um i kept on getting
these
phantom yeast infections i'll come back
i mean for months we just it would just
happen again happening and happening
again until i ended up contracting
fimosis
eight months later so at 20
20 years old 20 and a half i had to
undergo
a emergency circumcision
so that was another like two or three
weeks of rehabilitation but yeah it was
one of the worst experiences i've ever
had in my life
[Music]
um so the date of my suicide attempt
my mom kind of connected the dots and
made my sister go into my room to make
sure i wouldn't take anything again
and she had her search for the drugs in
my room too
so you know so i wouldn't take any more
and when she found that
the only thing she did was grab them and
then
she was like found it and then she
called my mom to tell her that they were
there but then she threw them back at me
and left the room even though she my mom
asked her to
you know watch me so that i wouldn't
finish the bottle
and then at that point i
thought she just wanted me to you know
actually
die so i took more and
ever since then i think about that
moment and think
of whether or not she actually wanted me
to die or not
and it's hard because my relationship
with my sister hasn't
always been the best but
we're definitely closer now which i'm
grateful for but yeah that's my secret
so when i was in elementary school i was
at a sleepover with some of my
girlfriends
and i accidentally stepped on my
friend's speaker and broke it
and i knew that she would get more mad
at me than the other girls
or like one of the other girls so then i
took the speaker while they weren't
looking
and hid it under a blanket so that the
girl that she would get the least mad at
would like jump off the bed directly
onto the speaker
so that's exactly what happened and she
jumped onto it and they heard a crunch
and they thought that she broke it
instead of myself didn't get mad at the
girl had a drama free sleepover
she still doesn't know but yeah
so a while ago i faked that i spoke
english for like three months to a group
of
americans down in panama but i actually
wasn't understanding anything they were
saying i was just laughing the entire
time either
whatever they were saying and then i
actually was able to learn
english
i was just saying like moving lines and
laughing at whatever they were saying
but i
had no clue what they were saying and
then i was able to understand and
you know actually speak english but
that's how i learned it it took me like
six months to like sort of get the
action first
and then like i started learning grammar
and all that complex stuff
but it all started like me thinking that
i was understanding like i would just
stare at them and be like yeah
[Music]
my secret is that i believe that i'll
only be able to fall in love a certain
amount of times
and i'm scared that when i fall in love
and i find the right person that i would
have fallen in love too many times and
that i won't have room for them
so my biggest secret is that i was at
the
route 91 las vegas mass shooting
and it forever changed my life for the
better
and the reason why it changed my life
for the better
is because i don't take life for granted
and i live for me
and i live for those people
and i live for the survivors
all of us
[Music]
i wrote a story about my mom she
she was driving my car and she had an
accident
so i needed to say that i was guilty
so she couldn't go to jail so i went to
jail and she doesn't know that i wrote
it
[Music]
i was homeless for over a year and at
one point lived on top of a bar
sometimes when i'm really mad with my
husband i regret marrying him
but then when i get not mad then i'm
really happy that i married him
and i feel like the luckiest woman alive
uh so i was in minnesota
like six years ago and i was chewing gum
at
at the time i ended up swallowing it
since it was a thing of swelling gum
but then i sneezed right after and it
came out my nose
that's about it
[Music]
so like two years ago i was driving
around this neighborhood at night and i
saw this cat
in the road and i guess in my mind i was
like there's no way i'm gonna run over
this cat obviously
but then i went on my phone to change
the song and i did kind of run over this
cat
and i felt terrible i went back and i
tried to like there was people that were
around they saw what happened
and i feel terrible about it i'm never
gonna go on my phone again but i still
feel really bad that i ran over it and
then i i did kind of lie to everyone and
say that it just ran out in front of my
car so i wouldn't look like i
look like an old a wall
[Music]
whenever i go to a target i steal at
least three things but i pay for one of
[Music]
them
when i was a little girl i once pooped
in a cat's litter box
yep
[Music]
i lost my virginity on my grimm's
mother's bed
[Music]
i'm original from china and
i smoked a lot of weed here and i drink
cloud alcohols and i party all the time
during my college i basically not study
but i still pass chemical engineering as
a major
so whatever works yeah my parents have
no clue
i stayed up until four and five every
single day smoking weed
and they thought i went to bed at 12 at
midnight and uh
they thought i'm a hard working student
but actually not
i do drugs i drink i do every single
thing a frat boy would do
okay so uh one day i was backing out of
my driveway
and i wasn't paying attention and i went
right into my mom's car
and i didn't really want to say anything
about it because she gets kind of angry
sometimes
so i just turned around and drove away
and about three days later
she asked if i knew what happened to her
car and
you know i told her no you know i don't
really know what happened she's like
well maybe somebody just backed into it
like in the parking lot i was like
you know what that sounds really
accurate i think that's what happened
and then yeah to this day i never like
told her about it and it's still kind of
picked up
wait i'm supposed to say that
okay so um about a year and a half ago
i like started becoming really close
with this girl and
i didn't know that i was a woman loving
woman at the time
so i didn't know that i liked her but
slowly that feeling like
perpetuated itself but she had a
boyfriend so i didn't really do anything
about it
and we got closer and i just gotten out
of a really
friendship so i was like super wary with
like calling people my best friend
but she said at first she was like
you're one of my best friends and i
said the same thing and then two months
later she
blocked me out of nowhere because of a
political tick-tock
and then um she like completely
abandoned me and so i'm like
have all that unresolved feelings for
her but not
like like i can't do anything about it
so yeah that's
that's my like secret i guess that like
i carried around for
over a year that i liked her yeah
[Music]
hey everyone quick announcement i
decided to make a separate channel for
my podcast
it's going to be linked in the
description the new channel is called
hey stranger which
as you know is the name of my podcast if
you enjoy watching the video versions to
my podcast
make sure to subscribe on there that
would mean a lot and then of course you
could still find the audio versions of
my podcasts on all the podcast platforms
and yeah that's pretty much it thank you
guys for everything
i love you all i'm happy to be back and
i'll see you next week you